Can you, can you not build a website? Can we just have the one pager? Can we have the ads running
the one pager and we charge a thousand and we spend 500 and take the difference? Yes, we can.
I've done it. I did it on accident and I've made money for a whole year, made whatever, six hundred
dollars, six thousand dollars net because it was thousand five hundred made 500 bucks a month times
twelve six thousand dollars net. Didn't even know. Yes, you can. However, I would highly, highly,
highly encourage you that once you get the deal and you get enough deals that your bills are covered
and you are like, OK, now it's time to go and build these properties that you take the profits
and you actually go and build the properties. OK, because this is the part that makes the business
model really sexy. OK, the business model is sexy even if you just do the arbitrage thousand bucks
a month, 500 and ads take the difference, but it becomes really sexy if it's a thousand bucks
a month that you're getting paid and you can turn the ads to 100 bucks a month or to 50 bucks a
month or completely off and you can make 90 plus percent profit margin. And OK, it also this is
another thing that's so dope about SEO is it mitigates your risk, right? If we're only relying
on ads and all of our leads are coming on ads, coming from ads, and then something changes with
ads, we're screwed. Right. So what I recommend is if Google has a way to get leads, let's try to tap
into all. Let's try to get leads from ads. Let's get leads from GMB and let's get leads from the
organic. We need to be we need to get. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. We need to be
getting all of this special delivery. Thank you. Of the monster told my wife to bring this thing
up because you just never know when I'm going to need that. Thank you. So we want to mitigate
our risk. We want to have leads coming in from ads. We have leads coming in from GMB and from organic.